[Music]
today we'll look at this
to Pompidou in the city of Paris it's a
cultural and art centre in the Marais
district on+ Beaubourg in Paris designed
by the team of Renzo Piano and Richard
Rogers the ultimate goal is to produce a
reading of the center that is
ideological to understand the
architecture as a mapping and a
representation of a historical moment
and a political condition on the one
hand the center was inspired by post
1968 philosophies of collectivity and
community but on the other hand the
project was an interpretation of new
cybernetic theories of information and
organization of on guard theatrical
principles cutting-edge technology and a
completely new attitude toward urbanism
and the practice of urban space the
ultimate goal was a building that was
support and represent freedom and change
in direct response to the desires of its
users the concept of architectural
imagination gives us a way of
articulating the relationship between
sort of everyday perceptual events
perceptual habits and conventions just
the kind of attitudes about being in the
world and the relationship of that
between the context which is usually the
city but also the social historical
context of those experiences so we can
think about it as two levels there's the
first level is existential and subject
centered it's just how we as individuals
are as a collective or are in the world
and that existential being in the world
the other which is really history itself
is sort of deep structural it concerns
the sort of objective conditions of
possibility for how we can be in the
world in other words different
historical moments different different
times different context allow ways of
thinking in a certain way allow ways of
behaving in a certain way but but those
ways are shifting through through time
if we can give an account of the context
that we can construct the context with
enough robustness with enough sort of
dynamism
then we can uh if you think about and
still continuing to think about the idea
of architectural imagination we can see
the building we can interpret the
building as an active mediator between
the context and our individual
experiences so so so a building because
it deals with space it deals with
material it even deals with uses and
activities in time can be not just an
inert object but an active mediator
between its historical context and our
understanding of that context so what we
want to do now is to think about the
Pompidou Center in the city of Paris at
a particular moment in time as a kind of
representation as a kind of registration
and is actually helping us produce an
understanding of a very particular
moment in history